pardon my relative
apartment and I want to welcome you to
the Schulman lectures and I'm going to
read this very important
notice the Schulman lectures are
presented under the auspices of the
Frankie program in science and
humanities which is made possible by the
generosity of Richard and Barbara
Frankie and they are extremely generous
the series is named after Robert
Schulman who is here tonight
sterling professor emeritus of chemistry
molecular biophysics and biochemistry
and senior research scientist in
diagnostic radiology in recognition of
his roles as a founding fellow of the
Whitney that's this and as an unwavering
supporter of the integration of science
and the humanities so can we thank
professor Schulman for his I also need
to thank Gary Tomlinson who runs the
Whitney such that we can have these
things going on Norma Thompson and Mark
Bauer who are organizing forces here
Sandra Malan Bowles and Anna Alber who
is the graduate assistant who's been
coordinating everything let me welcome
the students from the seminar of which
this speaker series is a kind of
spin-off the seminar is called reports
from nonhuman worlds whatever that means
we're trying to take a new set of
discourses which go under the names post
humanism transhumanism non humanism and
bring them back to their roots in some
older thinkers like Lucretia's about
whom you'll hear tonight shelling darwin
looks cool and we're asking two basic
questions what kinds of worlds might
there be and how can we even talk about
them the great gift of the showman
seminar is the ability to invite stellar
speakers working on topics that
illuminate these basic questions so let
me point out that on November 6th Clare
Colebrook from Penn State will talk
about the end of the world which seems
everyday less and less a fantastical
topic and October 2nd we have Manuel de
Landa who is very hard to get a really
fascinating sort of marginally academic
figure who will talk on philosophical
chemistry and what things look like from
the perspective of molecules today I am
delighted to present Jacques lesra
professor of Hispanic studies at the
University of California Riverside
professor lazara is always the center of
intense activity in both of his fields
that is spanish-language literature and
culture and comparative literature and
critical theory in one of his energy
centers he's an early modernist with
incredible scope three books on the
topic
most recently contra todos los Muertos
de la muerte Elsa says Oh 17 oh how do
you translate that against against all
deaths decrees the cervantean event but
this is as we'll see a risky business
translating before this he wrote
unspeakable subjects genealogy of the
event in early modern Europe and wild
materialism the ethic of Terror and the
modern Republic in another of his energy
centers and an energy center in the
field itself he has to theoretical books
about to come out first untranslated
machines a genealogy for the ends of
global thought and then on the nature of
Marxist things translation as necro
philology just as primary to his work as
authoring are translating and editing to
get a sense of the scope of this other
side I'll mention two bookends at an
early point he was partly responsible
for the translation of Paul de mons
blindness and insight into Spanish and
he recently co-edited the translation
into English of Barbara castles
dictionary of untranslatable x' which
project seems at a minimum paradoxical
lesra is not afraid of the paradoxical
he welcomes it turns it around rings
insights out of it we just saw this
happened live today in a seminar he
taught on Lucretia's as an example of
his fearlessness in the face of
paradoxes that seemed intractable and we
quote from the forthcoming on
translating machines quote my goal is to
describe a position of resistance to
even rebellion against the globalization
of culture that does not stand on commit
us or lead to fundamentalism for now I'm
giving it a paradoxical name an
untranslatable ax T which is not one in
an amazingly subtle investigation in two
types of untranslatable ax T you may not
be able to translate but you can tell
many many different reasons why
the other side of less Razak tivity
steps forward that is the political side
all his writing and para scriptural
activity works to liberate unfamiliar
and potent political perspectives even
ones that may seem in the present
paradoxical in this one regard I expect
tonight's lecture will be no different
he is here to lecture on atomic sex
Lucretia says material Republic please
welcome
Jacques Lazaro thank you so much and
please excuse my my eyes which are
particularly bad and no better for the
travel recent trouble so if I look up
blindly it's because I'm blind
looking up let's see as Paul mentioned
this talk is called atomic sex Lucretia
sees material Republic and when I
designed and devised the talk I thought
of the title more of a kind of
meretricious way of getting people into
lecture halls than as actually the topic
of the lecture nevertheless I found as I
was working through that I do end up
talking a fair amount about atomic sex
which is a strange thing to be talking
about in any event it's a great pleasure
let me say to be back in New Haven at
the kind invitation of Paul north and as
a speaker in this series named after
Robert Shulman intended to bring the
sciences and the humanities into
conversation the talk I'll be offering
you today flows in part from a sense of
puzzlement even upset at the way in
which institutions served over the past
electoral cycles in the United States
and in Britain to produce what I take to
be radically undemocratic outcomes the
regime currently in power in the United
States and brexit
is it possible i wondered from the debts
of some kind of agony to imagine
political institutions that are not or
are less susceptible of the sort of
mythologies that allow an electorate to
hope that their solidity of the
judiciary the constitution the rule of
law would protect the country from
driving toward anti-democratic outcomes
i was concerned and short to think about
republicanism in a way that evades or
minimizes establishing strong apparently
coherent institutions and thinks instead
of a republic of defective material
institutions my interest in the critius
precedes the election i hope and before
working my way into whatever it is the
Lucretia's provides in place of
mythological foundations for the
republic let me proceed to note how odd
it will be to approach the relation
between science and the humanities or
politics and philosophy by way of a work
written well before the modern sense of
science or the humanities or philosophy
or politics was set or even imagined and
so the project in bringing the fields
into conversation may appear perfectly
anachronistic it will seem especially
puzzling to turn for the archaic sources
of these conversations to Lucretia's de
rerum Natura a work notoriously
concerned to debunk the notion that
anything about culture is timeless and
resolutely critical of mythological
impulses at any moment if we imagine the
disciplinary field to meet and to be
mutually surveil
a timeless or mythological boundary
marker set deep in the ground of culture
and I'd like you to retain that little
image because it's kind of joke but I'll
come back to the image of a boundary
marker towards the end of the talk
in my consideration of the concept of
terminus and determination in in
Lucretius of course the greater and
prior puzzle may be why Lucretia says
work has made the spectacular comeback
we've seen in the past eight or so years
and why it would be bringing us together
today at all a return made on wings of
popular Pulitzer prize-winning works
like Steven Greenblatt's remarkable book
the swerve but also on the back of
retranslation 's conferences critical
anthologies of which i have been guilty
myself Lucretia says poem is the
workshop where Europe forges its
modernity from the epicurean thesis that
death is nothing to us and no concern of
ours Neil a little more zest add nos a
compact Restatement of the call in
Epicurus is letter to menaces to
accustom yourself to believe that death
is nothing to us for good and evil imply
awareness and death is the privation of
all awareness therefore a right
understanding the death is nothing to us
makes the mortality of life enjoyable
for life has no terror for those who
thoroughly apprehended there are no
terrorists for them in ceasing to live
working through Lucretia's subtly
forceful Restatement of Epicurus
doctrine European modernity shapes
itself when subjects no longer hew to
religious beliefs regarding the
afterlife or maintain the transcendence
of whatever it is that the human animal
values in a specific now when the
project of describing the nature of
things passes resolutely into the hands
of technicians specialists in what is
non transcendent scientific materialists
then we have a fall into a different
kind of modernity this is of course
gross caricature of both science and the
humanities
today in de rerum Natura European
modernity is invented and human freedom
is first sung the story goes but we
rediscover this twin circumstance
today and appreciated today just when
that freedom and the long priority
granted to the human animal itself
appeared to us in gravest peril will
object that the return to Lucretia's is
not really a return that european
philosophical culture has never really
been far from a work that always formed
part of a subterranean heterodox current
in philosophical thought as a French
philosopher French philosopher nuit and
herself would put it or will maintain
that de rerum Natura resurfaces today
because the conversation between science
and the humanities has tilted decisively
toward granting the first value and
priority over the second the scientific
paradigm over the humanistic one
Lucretia's comes back we return to
Lucretia's or we find ourselves again in
his company anachronistically a little
out of sync or out of time it's as if
these most contemporary crises of
globalization of institutional democracy
the crises in the conceptualization of
facts and alt facts of truth and the
regime of post truth somehow summoned
the millennial poem as if a poem
offering the modern european subject its
freedom from every benighted
superstition were somehow attuned to the
chaotic dynamism with which the
humanities and the human would come to
be subsumed by the science whose shape
the poem sings the serene pleasures of
the mind free from superstition
addressed in the epicurean garden yes
ataraxia this kind of serene pleasure is
on offer in the retina torah but also
the catastrophe the plague with which
the poem ends fire and fury
now the notion that we should treat
Lucretia says poem in part or maybe
centrally as the treatise of political
philosophy is not to put it mildly
generally accepted of course the poem
does concern itself with cosmological
principles of course such a matter as
the originally minimal swerve of atoms
remember this from the poem the
description of the laminar parallel flow
of atoms and their coming together
through a dickly not Co a movement a
swerve into producing bodies at random
or very uncertain times in uncertain
places of course the poem describes this
and this by analogy may entail an ethics
the ethics of free choice and yes the
strange doctrines of simulacra and of
sense perception that we find in the
poem misses again
those of you who are not immediately
conversing with the poem but in book for
Lucretia's describes how we receive
perceptions of bodies and as it happens
every body that you see around you is
emitting a absolutely thin film of atoms
in exactly the shape of the body and
that impresses itself upon our vision
this is the materialist account of
perception that we find in in the room
not Zura this strange doctrine of
simulacra and of sense perceptions we
find in the poem entail an epistemology
even an account of what truth is and
both of these taken together the account
of matter as swerving and the account of
simulacra and sense perception both of
these taken together offer a form of
historiography the Priuses relation to
Epicurus and then every subsequent
reading of Lucretia's could be
understood as a simulacrum relation in
which each one builds a simulacrum and
impress predecessor and swerves slightly
from it
maintaining some of the truth of the
original but also engaging in the
similarity in the imitation of it as
well a pedagogy is also to be found in
the rerum Natura so in this sense in the
sense that such primary matters underlie
the logically even chronologically
secondary questions of how human animals
enter into Association of what the
nature of these associations might be
how they're administered by whom into
what ends what institutions they entail
in this sense of course a poem about the
nature of things will always also be
about such things as human societies now
my suggestion is different and may
require a wholly different notion of
what politics is even aware it is
exercised and by what sorts of bodies de
rerum Natura bends to a triple task
first to embed in the nature of things
in their route most radically a form of
antagonistic being in common to be
marshaled against civil war a tendency
to Association and tailing and outlining
a political philosophy that I'm calling
material republicanism in second place
the poem shows that the being in common
embedded in the nature of things entails
a kind of anachronism a kind of
untimeliness you'll see what that is
about and third the poem bends to the
task of defining a poetics for the
untimely Material Republic the material
indivisible atomic republicanism that
Lucretia's offers swerves suddenly
minimally but decisively from the
classic conception of politics the poems
perspective is so distressing to that
classic conception of political
association that European political
philosophy itself swerves again away
persistently and violently away from the
material Republic that Lucretia's puts
on display what i lured Lee even
provocatively
and unknowingly called atomic sex a
strange image slowly developed over the
first three books of the poem and on
display for the Y years pleasure in the
fourth book of de rerum Natura atomic
sex is a figure of the material Republic
and the material Republic is
reciprocally a figure too for this
strange atomic dynamic and note this the
most characteristic but also among the
most difficult and controversial aspects
of Lucretia's project the task of
defining a poetics for the material
Republic is in no way secondary to the
task of embedding in the nature of
things their form of being in common or
the anachronistic untimely quality of
this being in common
it is not chronologically secondary and
not logically quite the contrary the
anachronistic untimely being in common
of Lucretia sees things is a poetics
their products so these are all rather
abstract claims so here's an example I
say that it's an example as if it were
one among many just any old example
what's at hand that's not right as I'll
show you this is the paradigm of
examples in the poem in some sense the
commanding example for the logic of the
poem take for example as if it were just
an example the highly controversial
account of the logic of sexual
intercourse from the fourth book of de
rerum Natura the architecture of the
poem places this primarily physiological
book after the books treating of the
nature of matter and the dynamics of the
indivisible Adam the first and second
books and the materiality of the soul
and the fear of death from which I cited
the epicurean thesis the death is
nothing to us and no concern of ours
yielding into a more assess diagnose
which we find in the third book right in
the middle of the power
the fourth book concerns the physics
even the physiology of thought the
domain of sense perception and
consciousness the doctrine of simulacra
that i mentioned their role in producing
a thought and experience and in
mediating a beings experience of the
world the book lays out the physics of
the senses proposes the extraordinary
thesis that all sense perceptions are
true
considers dreams optical illusions
nocturnal emissions the question of
intentional thought which must be
motivated on Lucretia's account by a
material image which is to say a
simulacrum of a hypothetical state of
affairs which because it's not yet the
case can only be true in a sense quite
different from the sense in which the
small apparent size of the immense Sun
or the round edges of a distant square
building might be true and then book
four turns to sexual desire motivated
also by the simulacra of bodies sex
being natural but not ontogenetic alee
necessary is an experience that the
epicurean philosopher will accept but
strive to keep to a minimum dynamics as
follows sex is a wound the effect of a
wound love caused by the image or
simulacrum of a body and a seminal jet
that follows the path of the wounding
image just as blood Lucretia's rather
vividly puts it gushes out toward the
wounding weapon and just as bodies will
usually fall in the direction of the
deadly blow
see communist East Austin ruber Oh Cupid
Umar if he is close by the enemy who
strikes the blow is first covered in red
or be spattered by the crimson stream as
Latham's translation has it a single
laminar image causes the wound and the
emission the image of a single body
wounds the lover he strives toward the
source of the wound and craves to be
united with it and to ejaculate the
fluid drawn from out of his body into
that body
yeah care a Amorim in Corpus the
carpenter doctor rather than hold fast
to that image though pining for the body
from which the laminar simulacrum flew
to wound us rather than hold fast to
that simulacrum or to the hope of
possessing the body from which the filmy
image detached since neither the
simulacrum nor the body will satisfy
what is after all a wound that's made
uncurable by our investment in both the
laminar phantasm of the body and the
body from which it detached rather than
cherish the one Lucretia's tells his
interlocutor many as a kind of play
boyish roman of the period and rather
stupid at least so the poem would seem
to suggest rather than cherish the one
body or the one simulacrum that is the
source of the wound Lucretia's tells
many 'us you should multiply the
emissions or the rose the verb is ya
katha to throw cast to hurl as most
famously in sweat oniy is's version of
caesar's exclamation Alea jacta s the
die is cast
well was merely possible has now become
necessary multiply the throws of the
dice multiplied the ejaculation
Lance the wound as often as possible d
consecrate the one wounding body and the
one wounding simulacrum by wounding
yourself again and again promiscuously
it's an extraordinary and still shocking
account this then is Venus for us it
says Lucretia's from this dynamic that
I've just sketched for you we take the
name love hake Venice s nobis pink
autumn autumn snowman amorous the fourth
books repeated coupling of immoral love
and Oh Maura what is liquid flowing a
humor that can be cast into the others
body this coupling of terms bears its
fruit in this verse which serves as a
kind of joke and as a definition but
also as the culmination of a sort of
lexical even alphabetical proof the
lover is mute but just here the verse
writes out in the coupling of amor and
umar the name and the genealogy of the
process that makes him mute the
clamorous contrast between the mute
striving body and the poetic means of
producing Naaman Amore's the name of
love or indeed the name of Venus however
bears a much heavier weight than would
first appear and this is what turns this
from being just any old example into
being the paradigm of exemplary T for
the poem recall
this is a trope of conversation recall
as if you had immediately just 20
minutes ago read the whole poem and had
it completely in front of you recall the
invocation that opens Maradona Torah
which addresses and dedicates the poem
to Alma Venice the mother of Aeneas
homonym de vermois libertas here many
verses later Lucretia's is producing
from within the poem as an effect of the
scrambling of the poems letters amor
amor anna chronically by placing the
origin and occasion of the poem right
here in the middle of the poem you just
hear Lucretia's produces for his
immediate addressee memnos the picture
that the figure of the poems ultimate
addressee Alma Venice Venice is produced
in book 4 though she is the addressee of
the poem from the very beginning it's
that a moment whose poetics the
promiscuous liquid movement of terms
between contrasting but also proximate
communist levels the alphabetical logic
stressing the analogy between letters
and the recombinant atomic minima that
compose our bodies the description and
production of its mythological divine
address see the remarkable gesture of
self pointing self indication heck hink
right here this is also an account of
the origin of the poem as if de rerum
Natura told the story of its origination
and of its destiny the place towards
where it is cast or thrown or hurled or
ejaculated the image of what it intends
and which forms and wounds the poem Alma
venues or menaces stolid ear or our eye
many centuries later just hear the poem
on the nature of things
is marvellously and scandalously not
just proximate to but synonymous even
identical with the poem on the nature of
the poem the poems object lies without
the poem but is also the poem itself a
paradoxical unfolding of the nature of
things in the effects that the poem
casts off mythological effects and
causes like Venus or effects and causes
apparently present to the speaking voice
of the poem like meh meais and notional
future effects and addresses to unfought
others like the readers of the poem that
we are whose laminar simulacra
possibility reaches the poem from the
moment in the future here and now and
which we work to piece together a
genealogy of the human animals birth and
crisis at the beginning of the 21st
century and at the seeming twilight of
the Anthropocene how though does this
Anna chronic invagination of causes
effects and times concern political
association as I've been maintaining and
connectedly
what do we make of the story's
negotiation of aleatory and necessary
logics of its see if logic its stress on
contingency
we're aware by now since reading through
the first two books of de rerum Natura
of the structural role that the atoms
contingent aleatory movement plays in
Lucretia's ontology and swerve or clean
Amin or decline at Co the uncertainty
that Lucretia's has expressed about that
event a minimal swerve occurring at
indeterminate times and places in kurtal
temper affair may incur t-square locus
patio swerves or moves or is thrown in
book four into the description of the
phenomenology of desire thus the
beloved's object his enemy is said
perhaps
be at hand to be painted red by
supporting blood see Caminos East Austin
Roberto Cuba to mark the stew the tense
strange coupling of the absolute term
omnis all bodies everybody and the
qualifying term generally karoon Quay
mostly usually ordinarily commonly most
often in the famous verse that
Lucretia's uses to describe first how
bodies fall towards a wounding hand
omnis play room quadrant in vilnius at
Elam Amica importance anguish and then
analogically how lovers strive to cast
their seed in the direction of the
laminar simulacrum that wakes their
desire and it's also the contradictory
imprecisions
of the verb yakety we throw the die
blindly we cast our lot we wound
ourselves again and again over the wound
of a first impression
inoculate amiss curiously and without
hope of reaching our end but we also
signify that our lot is now cast and
that although things might have been
otherwise they now follow necessarily
the path of effects the fourth book
precedes the historical books last two
of the poem how does Lucretia's
scandalous story which turns the physics
and physiology of thought and of desire
about the renewed and incurable wound of
love become a story regarding the
material republic here's a genealogical
way of proceeding to answer that
question or at least to address it since
I'm making a claim about the swerve that
Lucretia says text makes away from
classical republicanism and we first lay
out the sense of that term what is
classical republicanism
how does new critius sway from it or
swerve from it
look with me first at a text so a
well-known so universally consumed then
it's been almost unreadable for
centuries now part of the white noise of
philosophical pedagogy the seventh book
of Plato's Republic shortly after our
intrepid philosopher re-emerges from the
famous cave Socrates instructs Lacan
regarding the philosopher sovereigns
education thought is best and the
thought of the best man the ruler is at
its best when thought and the best man's
thought have learned Socrates says to
take as their objects the sorts of
things or disciplines which this is our
surest translation really do tend to
draw the mind to essence and reality
these objects that tend to draw thought
in the ideal direction are for instance
the sorts of things it can be thought
arithmetic Lee and arithmetics itself is
one such thing more generally
Plato the experiences that do not
provoke thought Socrates says those
objects of sensation that do not tend to
draw thought in the ideal direction or
as Allan bloom translates a rather
difficult passage those objects of
sensation that do not summon the
intellect are those that do not at the
same time issue in a contradictory
perception well the perception no more
manifests one thing then it's contrary
alike whether its impact comes from
nearby or afar this is a particularly
tricky moment and I'll show you a little
bit about the trickiness the moment when
a thought is provoked not by a
misprision but by a contradiction that
beginning in the senses reaches farther
and expresses a logical contradiction
and becomes what Plato calls a Perea and
Lamba do in his remarkable and
controversial hyper translation this is
when he calls it I don't know why not
call it something like that a hyper
translation of the Republic has Socrates
explained to Glaucon who's just as thick
in bud use text as in Plato's and to the
irritation of the much cleverer and
entirely invented figure of amantha that
this is now bud you those objects which
do not require pure thought are the ones
that do not produce simultaneously two
opposed sensations those which do
produce this opposition immediately I
class among those objects which set in
motion the frenches Kimo Belize which
set in motion pure thought the reason
for this is that in such cases
perception in no way clarifies the
question whether the object falls under
one predicate or its opposite provoked
summoned or mobilized by and into a
pariah thought pure thought but you has
it is able to make manifest a subsisting
unity in which the apparently
contradictory
sensible object participates the
question whether the object falls under
one predicate or another can at this
level be decided without injury to the
law of non-contradiction
a political ontology is forged here the
character of the properly philosophical
sovereign the subsisting character of
the laws to which he will turn to govern
the Republic the method pedagogical and
mayu tech of proceeding from the
sensible to the insensible which is also
a method of governance all of these are
made when thought is summoned from an
impasse observed at the level of the
senses to participate in a unity
disclosed in the domain of the forms
that thought can entertain and this
political ontology depends on the
conversion of one word the word that
I've been echoing in various translation
as the verb to provoke but use mobile
easy blooms to summon also another
translation to invite thought-provoking
mobilizing summoning inviting thought
that's what these objects proper the
inviting of thought do plato's Greek is
the verb in peep-toe which means to fall
in to fall upon with a semantic range
that covers such falls as falling under
a certain class or definition or also as
in Euclid the way in which a line falls
into relation to another or becomes
tangent to another one the contingency
of its contact in the Greek Gospels the
word and picked up ranges and sense from
to fall on ie to be entrapped by or
figuratively to be overwhelmed with or
to fall among it's used in expressions
that translate as to fall among robbers
or into someone's power but it's also
used of falling into a pit or into a
hole as when an animal falls into a hole
on the Sabbath and you have to deal with
that it is in short a very surprising
word to use when describing how an
object may or may not excite mobilise
invite provoke or fall into a fall upon
thought we might be even more forceful
the Platonic Republic stands on the
ground of the conversion of thought
understood as falling down into a hole
into thought understood as an peep-toe
falling under a class and general
category the platonic Republic stands on
very shaky ground if it's the former
that is the sense of falling as falling
into a hole accidentally is allowed its
full effectiveness if it's allowed to
drift in the direction that Epicurus and
then Lucretia's opened
do you see where I'm going with that
consider an alternative to the platonic
Republic still classic slightly
different a republic whose logic and
whose political ontology are based not
on eliminating the aleatory quality and
thought that plato's argument seeks to
reduce but on making that quality the
ground on which human association
unfolds the ground on which we can make
claims about the nature of historical
things and events on which we found and
seek to legitimate the power required to
address and manage these historically
contingent things and events in the
fifteenth chapter of the Prince
Machiavelli makes explicit one of the
treatises characteristic and most
influential manoeuvres which has been on
display since the famous simile in the
dedication to Lorenzo comparing the
project of writing for a prince about
the people to the cartographer who must
descend into the valley to judge the
mountains magnitude and ascend to assess
the valleys depth here in the fifteenth
chapter Machiavelli acknowledges the
trove of works preceding his that treat
the topic of the princes means of
governing the muddy and God need you
know príncipe consu d2o connelly amici
what the modes of government of a prince
should be with subjects and with friends
this is Mansfield's translation rather
than base himself in abstract
prescriptions or in the example
furnished by imaginary States or on
consideration of how one should live as
so many of these have done and here
Machiavelli is no doubt thinking of
Plato Machiavelli will he says go
directly to the effectual truth of the
thing rather than to the imagination of
it la varita effet wala de la cosa to
say rightly stressed the importance of
the singular Machiavelli turns to la
cosa the case the thing the event and
hence explicitly rejects accounts of the
nature of things and it's things which
would fall into or under or fall in a
class of abstract concept
a theoretical dispositive I'll to their
rights is here brought to light that
breaks with the habits of classical
rhetoric where the universal governs the
singular something else is going on
let's grant how to share this canny
insight I would want to stress the
oddity of the notion of effectivity
effective or effectual truth that's on
display in this conception of the
Republic the difficulty that translators
have with Machiavelli's expression is
symptomatic in 2003 Goodwyn translates
the affective reality of things in 95
wooden has how things are in real life
in 1683 I'm Lord Allah we say translates
parle suno la vérité lashes
according to the truth of the thing one
of the earliest Spanish translations
speaks of las casas commotion in la
realidad mansfield renders very tough
etoiles as the effectual truth of the
thing which is very good literal but
doesn't mean very much in english
effectual truth certainly doesn't mean
what it does in the Italian in
Machiavelli the criterion of the truth
ascribed to the thing or the case or the
act bears on its effect its effectual
'ti it's an outcome and not only on its
reality things as they are or the thing
as it is rather than as its imagined to
be sure but also and simultaneously the
thing according to its outcome or
effects the criterion of effectual T is
not its time notoriously to the
foundation of the Republic as when at
the beginning of the discourtesy
Machiavelli writes of the murder murder
though the deed accuses him the result
should excuse him was unduly fat own
wife Ethel Oh scusi two different
dispositions to the thing la cosa and to
determining or establishing the truth of
the thing or things are entailed
Machiavelli will not seek to resolve
them but instead found the Republic on
their mutual interference
what you will ask has passed between the
Platonic Republic and the Machiavellian
Republic between the reduction in
thought to the one and the
chronologically split criterion of
thought and judgment that grounds the
Machiavellian Republic it will not
surprise you to hear that it is
Lucretia's as work that intervenes that
his embedding of contingency in the
nature of things and in the logic of
their poetic articulation rescues the
fall and beep tone from which platonic
thought recoils and multiplies that fall
that throwing as a condition on which we
come together let me show you how the C
logic I sketched through you in book 4
Thanks concrete political shape and
embeds in the nature of things a form of
political association this again is
another example that seems to be just
any old example it's what's at hand that
turns out to be also paradigmatic how
many paradigms can you have well in
Lucretia's as it happens you have a lot
of contrasting paradigms this is another
paradigm for exemplar utley generally we
move from book for treating the matter
of perception and sexual desire as we
just saw two books five and six which
concern human history we memy as' and we
products like venus of the poem are
presumed to recall the previous books
this is the order of the demonstration
in the poem this is the structure of
epicurean pedagogy the path to ataxia
the route to the garden of Epicurus
having learned not to fear death and as
a consequence not to depend upon
religion not to think that figures like
Venus have an external life we may pass
from cosmology to sociology to the
foundation of civil society politics on
this description enters late after many
other lessons have been learned by that
sometimes Lucretia's writes it may
happen that men who have learnt the true
about the carefree existence of the gods
fault a wandering by what power the
universe is kept going math instruction
continues then after they fall to
wandering because they have forgotten
these lessons then the poor creatures
are plunged back into their old
superstitions and saddle themselves with
cruel masters dominoes a curious whom
they believed to be all-powerful all
this because they do not know what can
be and what cannot how the power of each
thing is limited and its boundary stones
buried deep
quit quiet si quit neck wet finita
potestas Danny quake week we wanna see
tatiana art grant the terminus eyelids
fantastic stuff there's a great deal to
this little passage which closes the
program to the fifth books recasting the
poems pedagogical project in explicitly
political terms we do not remember not
to fear death if we do not remember that
all things carry buried within their
term and find it if we forget in short
what we have read in the Red Room
naturae then we will grant power to
cruel masters and invest them with the
divinity and the powers and the
mythology we see ourselves to lack as if
in compensation as if transferring to
the sovereign what we know ourselves to
lack would somehow complete us or keep
our own finitude from our door it's
entirely consistent with the poems
project to imagine that the lessons it
seeks to convey will be forgotten
however even by the best pupils and that
the epicurean lessons regarding human
fine a tune the souls materiality and
the world's paradoxical limit no matter
how well sweetly and convincingly
imparted will tend to fade disaggregate
fly apart
decay like any other material thing a
lesson is also a material object with
the same consistency of atomic lamin
arity as a perception and for that
reason it suffers the same fate as any
perception as any material laminar image
simulacrum it decays we forget it this
puts us in a paradoxical situation a
lesson about the world is a simulacrum
of the world hence a laminar material
composite that the world casts off one
of a near infinity of simulacra whose
hold on our attention and judgment and
memory is as ephemeral as the coherence
any composite body will exhibit in the
nutrition cosmos where minima combined
catch on to one another according to the
laws of nature the federa naturai
and then this aggregate to recombine in
brief has letters that make sense in a
word will soon make other sense in
another word the paradox is most
apparent though it has a tragic
component quite at odds with the serene
disposition to which the poem would lead
us i Lucretia's will provide you with a
lesson which you will forget because not
to forget it to intend a lesson you
would not forget to intend to plant most
deeply and immovably within you the
awareness of your own finances laminar
material siccola simulacrum of the world
an ideal form although i teach you that
you and the world have limits though
these are of different sorts these
limits and no matter whether you learn
my lesson most carefully and bury it
deeply in your understanding that lesson
which is the expression of your and my
finances also obeys the rule that it
teaches finite material lamb
my lesson a simulacrum of the world
comes undone and must be retaught in
other words in other letters again and
again without necessarily ever being the
same lesson this is an excuse for
infinite pedagogy so those of us who
have professional lives in the
university can be very happy about this
because the lesson goes on or not you've
destined to forget it and I'm destined
to repeat it and reteach it and that's
you know that's how one draws one's
salary the passage is tenner however is
explicitly political the matter is not
as abstract as I've made it seem a sort
of reflection on the performative
failures of pedagogy but it concerns
instead the compensatory investment of
mythological power in the sovereign the
master the possessor the ruler the Lord
the proprietor the owner the Dominus who
may of course also be the teacher or the
Pentagon Dominus in the Republican
period is a highly charged term in the
dorinda Republic a Cicero for instance
makes the term synonymous with the Greek
tiranos minimally we appear to be in the
grip of a performative contradiction it
seems that the better the more
convincing and the more long-lasting the
lesson that the poem offers the lesson
will fade but it's fading it's this
aggregation it's proof in act of the
lesson which should then best succeed
when most intends to be forgotten the
political lesson is even more troubling
we will
we must never fail to invest dominoes
with mythological power since we're
condemned to forget the sovereign lesson
planted deep within us by our master
Epicurus by his pupil apprecia s-- and
his readers Machiavelli and Hobbes their
student Karl Marx and so on the long
underground current of material
materialist philosophers who seek to
teach us to forget to forget the lesson
of the finite of everything and every
tyrants power
they're potestas I've been insisting
that the performative contradiction here
is only apparent let me show you what I
mean and close by showing you what sort
of logic and politics might be entailed
in the poems passage from cosmology into
the level of sociology and politics
recall the figure that Lucretia's uses
to describe the poor creatures who
forget the lessons offered by the
clear-sighted epicurean philosopher he
says still Letham the poor creatures are
plunged back into their old
superstitions and saddle themselves with
cruel masters dominoes Socrates whom
they believed to be all-powerful all
this because they do not know what can
be and what cannot how the power of each
thing is limited and its boundary stones
buried too deep the verse repeats
exactly the words with which the figure
of Epicurus is introduced in book one
Lucretia says a man of Greece was first
to raise mortal eyes and defiance first
to stand erect and brave the challenged
fables of the gods did not crush him
rather they quickened the keen courage
of his heart so that he first of all men
still Epicurus longed to smash the
constraining locks of nature's door he
proclaimed to us what can be and what
cannot how the power of each thing is
limited and its boundary stone sticks
buried deep again finita palace tossed
any quick-quick where wonnum seat
Eruzione earth quail hunt the terminus
herons laughter is quite literal in his
translation of both iterations of the
verse the word terminus is indeed a
boundary stone it is the mark that
determines where one field ends and
another begins and metaphorically where
the semantic field that one term covers
or indicates ends and another begins a
word like science will have one semantic
ray
the humanities another at the boundary
between them a terminus stands or lies
or is embedded terminus is also as
readers of ovens fast II would recall
the name of the God who watches over
boundaries the terminalia the gods
festival is celebrated on February 23rd
and he turned to Ovid's description of
the festival for a sense of the dense
cultural and philosophical work that the
name does in Lucretia's
this is now Ovid one night has passed
let the god be celebrated with customary
honor who separates the fields with his
sign terminus whether a stone or a stump
buried in the earth you have been a God
since ancient times
your crown from either side by two
landowners who bring two Garland's and
two cakes in offering ceremony proceeds
think of this also as the great
predecessor of Robert Frost's poem
ending wall that seems to me to be
behind so the ceremony proceeds the
marker is reset coals or cinders are
added to renew the mark hidden deep
below the ground then neighbors gather
sincerely and hold a feast and sing your
praises sacred terminus when neighbors
sing to terminus you set bounds to
people's cities great kingdoms without
you every field would be disputed you
Corino favor you aren't bribed with gold
guarding the land and trusted to you in
good faith to populous or best quit
raining india finis omnis edits in at a
little yo soos agora the fantasy that
Ovid expresses is noteworthy the sincere
neighborly ceremony celebrating the god
of limits
boundaries boundaries of property
ethnicity political dominion and
sovereignty this replaces the dispute to
which humans would otherwise be
condemned
omni's Eddie sin eh-tey the euro saga
every field disputed a war of all
against all
without terminus without the term but
Lucretia's will not settle on this
ritualistic politics on substituting the
ceremony of community in place of
limitless war on song address to the god
of boundaries on gathering sincerely
simply at the edge of one territory like
the neighbors in mending wall' such
rituals de rerum Natura tells us flow
from thought that converts fear the fear
of death the fear of financing financing
of cities ethnicities people's into
sovereign even tyrannical Authority in
this case a tyrannical authority of
terminus itself in as much as it remains
buried and can be returned to in this
foundational way de rerum Natura is
paradoxical topology maintains
determination buried deep but also
inscribes it on the surface of the poem
or rather it asks its readers to imagine
a simulacrum of depth the laminar
surface of its depths and a simulacrum
of its surface as its letters it asks
its readers to countenance the figure of
a defining term that is both historical
separated from the present rituals by
historical accidents the oldest of God's
but is also entirely the product of the
present of a repeated ritual in the
present the condition for the coming
together of neighbors the condition on
which a republic that does not
- the one can be imagined is to maintain
as a condition of its possibility its
insistence on both these levels that is
on condition that the poem should
poetically open and reopen when book 4
called the wound of love that being
struck by a simulacrum - whose object
and whose simulacrum we cleave
unsatisfied out of time thank you no no
you why don't you answer the question No
because
they
yeah
not
we were assisting
standing office
also
yes so I made my teabag no it's the the
opening of book to that wonderful
wonderful description of as you say that
it doesn't have to be a philosopher it
can be just anyone who's watching the
shipwreck bloomin burg writes about this
also so typically that moment is taken
to be an example of the kind of
indifference or or distance that the
philosopher has to seek to achieve so
that if you read through and work
through all of the railroad naturae you
will achieve a position where you can
have the kind of stoic indifference or
epicurean indifference to the suffering
of others because you've achieved a
capacity to disengage with with that
person with whom you're identifying
there so a political reading such as I'm
suggesting does not base its politics on
identifying with the people who are
drowning I think this would be the a
crucial way to approach this and so the
the trajectory of the poem then could
very well lead towards a kind of
indifference but that would not be where
the political import of the poetry would
be it's not because I do or do not
identify with the people whose anguish I
see there it's not because I'm solicited
by those others and by my identification
with them that I would then become part
of a political process of some sort but
because thought itself is constituted as
a kind of sharing and disputing with
others so it's not my identification
with another it's just that the
structure of thinking is political at
its core and that politics is entirely
independent of my identifying are not
identifying with
or the pleasures of some other person
that could happen but that's not the
level at which political association is
understood to be occurring in the poem
now this is it's it's a controversial
reading of the poem because it's
counterintuitive with regard to just
that kind of moment and because so many
of the statements in the poem are about
achieving ataraxia or a kind of
equanimity and serenity that would seem
to imply an indifference to the for the
fate of others and it may well imply
that indifference but that's not where
the poems political import lies I was
arguing but rather it lies in the
structuring of thought as accidental as
well as necessary as falling in the
sense of falling under the category as
well as falling as in a sense of
swerving or or declining doesn't answer
it entirely but somewhat
kind of this mentality
defective material institutions
imagine the garden of Epicurus it's an
enclosed this is now we're talking about
the western imaginary of the epicurean
project what's cool cool is the
technical term is you know what's cool
about a bikini ism is that it leads you
to the garden and at that point this is
the imaginary construction of it at that
point you have serenity contemplation
and walking around
on the account that I give the walls
separating the garden of Epicurus that
is the domain of reflection and and
serenity from a humdrum busy world of
may go to UM outside of it those walls
are not just imaginary but they are like
these terms or the determinations they
are the kind of foundation that leads to
the installing of the the tyrant so on
the reading that I'm giving the the
garden of Epicurus it's not that it
loses its walls it understands the
setting aside of a space for reflection
serenity and so on as being the effect
of a an act of force that creates
tyranny think about this in less
abstract terms and think of the
university as the epicurean garden the
Hortis conclusively enclosed garden of
the university maintains its enclosure
by means of an act of force constantly
repeated active force just as the
constant yes of the act of love or
lovemaking is constantly repeated that
wound is constantly iterated what this
analysis of Lucretia's permits us to do
one hopes is to like I called it D
consecrating to D consecrate the garden
and deacons end to under and to
understand that the wahlid nests of the
garden is a matter of force so it has
this kind of analysis has as an
immediate consequence a rethinking of
not just the physical structure of the
university in its relation to the
community but also of how thought has to
be understood in relation to practice or
to may go to you the old odium the
gaudium relation has to be rethought as
a matter of force and the Republic that
be installed on the basis of the
critique of the force required to
install the tyranny of the walls around
reflection would be that I was calling a
defective or a material republic now
when I talk about institutions or
defective institutions there again this
topology of an institution that is
limited in its in its self definition
and enclosed by a wall that is designed
to this end or to that other end that's
what needs to fall that's what comes
under critique as well institutions as
self constituting self-preserving and
self prolonging self legitimating
autopoietic and closed Gardens those
that conception of the institution needs
to fall as well and what takes its place
is a conceptualization of a republic as
a loosely articulated nexus of defective
that is non self enclosed institutions
which are much harder to mythologize at
least this would be the prince of Bolton
since we don't have one it's hard to
know whether it's true or not but well
they're defective but in a different way
right so you'd say the defects of the
judiciary right now are that they don't
achieve the utopian ends to which
they're entailed the defectiveness that
I have in mind is an effectiveness that
claims that they're they can never be
suited to their goals that a conception
of an institution suited to a particular
goal is itself problematical and that I
think could flow from
analysis that I'm doing here
it's
Oh
ah it's hard to be a materialist because
you get asked questions like this all
the time it's like well who's taking the
garbage out Jacque if all this here's a
trivial answer no no no I know but a
trivial answer would be to say something
like this the task of this is not only
trivial but it's wrong but it's it but
it's interesting so that the task of a
philosopher lie Lucretia's is to take
out the garbage he takes out the
conceptual garbage he clears off the
landscape and says this this trope is
useless this trip has been used too much
now we can recycle it we can throw it
out and go so the landfill outside of
the garden in the garden we have only
the new stuff the reason that's trivial
and the reason that it's wrong is that
there is no garbage in philosophy a
everything is it seems to me useful
usable if not now at a point which is
indeterminate in the future and so it's
not there is no such thing but more
importantly I think it leaves out the
actual question of labor in the Republic
who works what works who is the slave
who is a master who works for what so
that's a question that said it I I
wasn't addressing it it wasn't part of
my my canvas but it's a crucial question
and it has to follow somehow from what
I'm what I'm saying and I think that the
presumption would be that and it's
absolutely utopian sort of presumption
the presumption would be that in the
sort of Republic that in my view
Lucretia's is
announcing installing provoking
producing the any form of domination
that would produce unremunerative or
enslaved or exploited labor would be
immediately understood consider not
immediately would be understood as a
conceptual problem and could be treated
conceptually within the frame of this
Republic as something to be avoided
entirely right it's as I say it's at
that level that I'm that I'm thinking
about this there's a separate argument
that has a historical argument about the
actual villain of Epicurus
and the actual garden which from what
has been reconstructed as far as I
understand was hardly a haven of
communal living and and enter and and
happiness but rather was a highly
hierarchical and very stratified micro
society that's not good
and if that's the case then Epicurus was
being a really bad epicurean or maybe he
was being a very good epicurean and a
really bad and accretion philosopher
of all the boundaries perhaps and these
accusations yeah yeah
I have wonder how use that you came to
this through Regis and I wonder how to
square that with where you ended your
talk where reaches is emphasizing the
necessity of preserving sacred
boundaries between things and between
concepts okay [ __ ] revoking his use
of the word Tigers yes delicious
delicious is not a kind of mark Uzi and
fuzzy person who doesn't believe in the
puss in the necessity of boundaries but
he that is he believes that in
terminalia he believes in the existence
of terminus but he also installs a
respect for the simulacrum of the
terminus and says that in the division
between those two you get the
possibility of establishing a kind of
Republic whereas Ovid to my mind is much
more interested in the ritualistic
anthropology that only will attend to
the Buried terminus and not to as it
were the surface poetics of terminus and
it's to my mind what Lucretia's achieves
by evoking the Buried terminus but also
making it necessary to think about the
simulacrum terminus that is the surface
of the poem what he manages to do in
that way is what he does in book 4
concerning sex or just to say we can't
rest or and we cannot be satisfied
either with the simulacrum or with the
object of which it is
and for that reason sexuality in book 4
is always like an unsatisfiable hunger
it's it's it's a an interesting trip
ology it's a little bit different from
the avidians apology concerning
concerning love but when you translate
it into the political domain you get
this quite I think striking use both of
the necessity of occasional
foundationalism terminus as buried and
the investment in this kind of poetics
of the surface of the poem of the letter
of the de cemento cessation of the poem
which makes it much harder to
mythologize and to think of terminus
only as the the ritualistic God buried
deep below
the ashes
I hadn't but it's it's but I'm very glad
to notice it through your eyes
a lot
and yes my question
in those
what kind of you have in my mind it
doesn't seem incompatible
and I would like to pause and God also
look boom is there or the Lucretia's is
this impossible
I don't think the nutritious believes in
progress now that doesn't mean that
there isn't groom for possible optimism
it's just that it's not connected to any
kind of progressivism in history it's
also necessarily if you follow the
Grisha is not connected to any kind of
will to power over the past because the
will is has a mental circumstantial and
contingent as anything else in the
material world or more so so one could
want to will over the past in order to
change it or one could wants will over
the future in order to change it but
that willing doesn't necessarily have
any effects that are the ones that are
intended you have entirely different
effects the grounds for optimism it
seems to me on in a Lucretia and vein
partly come from that that is it because
the relation between causes and effects
is poisoned absolutely by the aleatory
quality of events things are possible
that is it's a modal to modal world in
that sense rather than necessary there's
a problem with pedagogy or the
pedagogical problem here that you
identified whywould Lucretia's right the
poem on the nature of things if the
lesson that it imparts is destined to be
forgotten at all that in itself it just
goes to maybe Josep is word tragic that
tragic condition of the philosopher who
performs something or who teaches
something which by its performance
eliminates itself cancels itself out and
nevertheless does it seems for the first
five and a half books of
the remnants are precisely the position
that he's taking the problem arises at
the end with the catastrophe of the
plague at that point one reading of it
is to say well Lucretia's goes mad this
is st. jerome he realizes that the poem
that he's been writing has no capacity
to convince in a lasting and enduring
way and that this poor mem is that he's
created out of whole cloth as the
interlocutor is forgetting as you know
as Lucretia speaks and this
allegorically is represented as the
plain so that that's one very strong way
of reading of reading the poem another
way of reading the conclusion another
way is to say well the idea would be
that by the end of book six the
appropriate student a good student has
reached the position where she can
observe the catastrophe from the point
that Catrin was saying as though she
were watching the disaster of a book
book but of a boat sinking at sea that
is I can go from watching the suave
mighty magnitude to watch it from
watching the ship sink and feel a
certain kind of distance and then by the
end of six I could watch the world go up
in fire and fury and be okay with that
too now my view is that Lucretia is
doing neither of those two things that
the catastrophe is there to provoke a
contradiction in the conceptualization
of the pedagogy into it because maybe an
example of it such that you get to the
end of the poem and you cannot resolve
whether you've learned to be serene or
whether the world actually is ending and
you should feel empathetically towards
it and
and tragically as a result serenity and
tragedy
seemed to me to be held together in hand
at the end of the rerum Natura and that
disposition seems to be what effectively
is required for the material Republic
[Applause]
[Music]